right and he already told you why he's
doing it it's not for the greater good
he said we can't win against AI so we
need to combine with AI he told you this
on The Joe Rogan interview clear-cut
well AI is going to be the next uh
people don't understand the significance
of artificial intelligence uh Vladimir
Putin has called it uh the next nuclear
weapon and the country that develops it
first will have uh ultimate uh potential
to have total world to domination with
it so when it comes to this power who
would you rather have this latest
technology this is the question that I
think maybe uh some uh Elon Musk Fanboys
are asking themselves do you want China
to have that power do you want alphabets
to have that power or Google uh the
Pentagon or do you want Elon Musk who is
representing the larger ideas of Free
Speech but at the same time if you're
doing that you shouldn't be wearing a
Satan costume that's worth uh nine
thousand dollars and still have it as
your main profile picture on Twitter and
he changed his location to hell but my
issue
I didn't see that yeah he changed his
location on Twitter